[Musique]
c'est un débat qui n'en finit pas de
diviser l'euthanasie d'autos neuves et
d'occasion cette méthode qui consiste à
aider les personnes atteintes de
maladies incurables à mettre fin à leur
vie en leur administrant une injection
létale
si en europe déjà cinq pays donne droit
juste assister les pays bas la belgique
la suisse le luxembourg et plus
récemment l'espagne
la question se pose toujours en france
hier l'assemblée nationale examinait la
proposition de loi du député olivier
falorni regroupant cinq articles ce
texte propose d'ouvrir un droit à une
fin de vie libre et choisit mario
barravecchia ancien candidat de la star
academy a été confronté à cette décision
de viol noir vis-à-vis de son père
atteint de la maladie de charcot
hospitalisés en belgique il a décidé de
signer l'accord lui permettant de mourir
dignement est avec nous ce soir pour
nous expliquer son choix
merci mario est là bonsoir à tous que
voilà un amour de mecs j'ai rencontré il
ya très longtemps
c'est vrai lors de la star academy j'ai
dû faire ma première émission t après la
star ac / communie avec toi et ouais
exactement c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai et il est toujours
sympathique en 2009
bah c'est vrai que c'est bien sûr le
candidat emblématique de l'as première
saison la star ac mais en 2009 mario tu
à vivre un long drame
ton père est atteint de la maladie
incurable de maladie de charcot il va
choisir l'euthanasie aujourd'hui il
vient nous raconter l'histoire ne sont
pas pas juste vous est ce que vous êtes
autour de la table ce que vous faites
pour légalisation de l'euthanasie en
france allant c'est au bout oui oui
parce que moi je moi j'écoute les
témoignages de ceux qui souffrent et qui
se passe par là y compris ceux qui ont
accompagné les gens qui ont qui ont
demandé à partir alors soit par une
euthanasie soit par une sorte de suicide
assisté et je me rends compte de la
douleur et de la souffrance et je trouve
que c'est extrêmement bien encadrés ce
que ce qui est proposé est qu'en france
actuellement pour l'instant il ya une
sorte d'hypocrisie
ja je me suis renseigné entre 2000 et
5000 l'euthanasie en france qui ne
disent pas leur nom c'est à dire que
dans les hôpitaux on fait ce qu'on
appelle notamment la sédation profonde
et continue c'est à dire et quand
quelqu'un dit je veux arrêter maintenant
j'en ai assez en fait on débranche tout
qui ont aimé dans une sorte de coma
alors une forme d'euthanasie
donc j'aimerais que compte leur
permettent de terminer les jours comme
il souhaite déterminer ces jours là
alors mardi sur lci à david pujadas qui
animait un débat sur le droit à
l'euthanasie est une séquence a beaucoup
fait parler c'est barbara lefebvre une
essayiste fermement opposé à
l'euthanasie qui a eu des propos très
cash haut la main on vous annonce une
terrible maladie neurodégénérative du
genre maladie de charcot effectivement
vous savez quelle va être l'issue que
l'issue va être effectivement non
seulement de la souffrance et que les
soins palliatifs dont vous pourriez
bénéficier ne sont pas toujours pas
développer comme il le faudrait et ça
c'est une question si de financement de
volonté politique
et bien vous pouvez très bien vous
suicider voilà mais on n'a pas à exiger
que dans la loi soit fait état que ce
suicide et vous excusez moi je vais être
très très très très vial mais quand on
vous annonce une maladie incurable vous
n'êtes pas encore en état végétatif vous
sauter d'un pont
je veux dire il ya un moment donné alors
des mais non ils diront c'est horrible
les fourmis c'est inadmissible je suis
totalement en désaccord avec cette
phrase en revanche pour moi il ne faut
pas légaliser l'euthanasie
valérie il l'a dit a déjà la loi
leonetti avec les soins palliatifs
moi je dis respect absolu de la vie
humaine et je dis que mon risque pour
moi de profiter de la butte faiblesse
est à dire de gens faibles qui ne vont
pas pouvoir dire vraiment je veux mourir
et on risque à ce moment là de les tuer
parce que s'il vient de ça parce que
danse il s'agit selon qu'on sorte que tu
sais que alors est proposé c'est que
c'est encadré qui aura un bel hommage de
médecins au minimum deux voire trois
médecins
il faut que la demande soit réitérée par
le patient à plusieurs reprises et que
par ailleurs l'issue soit inéluctable
fatal est que le patient souffre le
martyr à partir de tout cet encadrement
là ça existe en belgique en espagne en
justement il va aussi en belgique
c'était un cadeau j'aimerais me reçut ce
que cette dame a dit c'est totalement
irrespectueux pour le pour le patient
qui souffre mais aussi pour les familles
elle a parlé de la maladie de charcot
moyenne chaque mois la marque au cc la
sclérose latérale amyotrophique c'est
une maladie neurodégénérative
il n'y a pas de remède c'est une maladie
en trois à cinq ans maximum la pergola
le patient nord mon père ça a été en six
mois donc jour au lendemain vous l'avez
vu vous avez vu son état j'aimerais en
fait il m'a appelé j'étais en studio et
m'appellent son frère mon parent a
malheureusement et est mort de la même
maladie l'année d'avant c'est très rare
dans notre famille est le cousin germain
aussi en italie qu'à me voilà bref donc
ils m'appellent il dit je la même
maladie que mon frère effectivement cccc
choc total et donc on essaie d'aller
voir d'autres professeurs et donc je les
amenais la salle l'hiver quand ils vous
appeler pour vous dire ça il savait déjà
pour lui ça va être très compliqué parce
qu'il avait vu mon frère on venait
d'enterrer son frère quelques mois avant
et d'ailleurs apparemment ce serait un
choc émotionnel qui a développé ce se se
gêne à ce moment là et le pire c'est que
mon père avait toute sa tête
c'est ça qui est très grave je suis à
dire quand quelqu'un n'est pas conscient
de ce qu'il est en train de devenir bon
là lui il avait toute sa tête il se
voyait dépérir il pouvait plus parler
pourrais plus m'en j'avais cas là je
vois pas il avait 54 ans 54 ans est
effectivement donc il habite en belgique
je faisais des allers retours en
belgique et est abandonnée bas
vous avez vu que j'avais vu son état
empirait de jour en jour oui au début
c'était de semaine en semaine et après
sept jours en jours quand si je me
rappelle d'un repas la bndes gêne quand
il commençait à laval et à déglutir et
ils disaient ils me disaient pas mais
voulait me faire comprendre que ça
commençait et donc quelques semaines
après peu de plongée et donc puis ça va
très très vite celui-ci a été rapidement
en été transporté a été transporté à
l'hôpital une première fois au bout de
combien de temps il a été transporté à
l'hôpital
4-4 mort à quatre cinq mois au bout de
quatre mois après il a été déclaré qu'on
est en effet un peu de quatre mois il ya
le plus respirer donc on a pris
l'addition de longs tubes et ce qu'on
nous appelle d'abord pour nous demander
l'autorisation de le faire et je voulais
le faire parce que je ne lui il reste
peut-être un miracle de la rose voilà et
il en tubes et pendant combien de temps
aux le dernier le dernier mois
facilement dans les mois et il a aimé
qu'l river et m'écrivez des choses à
l'hôpital pour me demander justement
d'accélérer le processus pour le pour
l'euthanasie en fait ce qui ce qui
choque les français les gens aiment et
moi c'est le mot euthanasie qui je pense
n'est pas adapté un ah voilà à cette
morale étriquée finalement voilà et donc
je lui faisais en croire que j'allais le
faire j'ai donné autorisation parce que
je au début je voulais pas parce qu'on a
l'impression de donner la mort à son
père mais mais en même temps il me
demandait me disais que si c'était pour
vivre comme un légume
et puis tous les médecins et médecins
entoure le diagnostic était précis c'est
à dire il allait mourir c'était malheur
dans deux semaines c'est comment comment
il vous l'a annoncé qu'ils voulaient
prendre cette décision de partir de
lui-même il n'a toujours dit ça il m'a
dit que si un jour il devait respirer
avec une machine qui voulait pas se voir
voilà il était très jeune parce qu'il
avait il avait 54 ans et déjà il vous
parlez de ça déjà vent debout
oui il a toujours dit si un jour je
devais mourir enfin il voulait pas
rester dans un fauteuil roulant ou dans
un lit médicalisé et sait comment ils
vont l'annoncer en écrivant en écrivant
là il me regardait
il pouvait plus bouger donc il avait
juste le doigt les deux trois doigts que
vous pouvez écrire très difficilement et
il me demandait donc et m'a dit il faut
le faire c'est le moment partir il m'a
dit rappelle-moi la maison donc il
voulait pas mourir l'hôpital
donc vous l'avez ramener à la maison
voilà les médecins n'étaient pas
d'accord parce que c'est tout un système
médical autour de rapatriement compliqué
mais je dis goutelle et c'est du moins
la liberté de mourir à la maison
tranquillement
et puis médecin traitant vient de trois
jours après médecin de famille et il me
dit mario ben il faut y aller de façon
là il
il dort il souffre il est plus conscient
morphine morphine et ses médailles a
rejeté les deux jours qui va arriver
voilà et e
le médecin c'est par petites doses en
fait c'est vraiment très il ne souffre
pas le patient ne font pas ça dépend de
la méthode
voilà et c'est là bas c'est une seringue
ou lui injecte un produit mais je vais
demander de le faire vraiment sur toute
la journée
voilà et finalement j'ai pas été au bout
j'ai pas été au bout mon père m'a dit
que il voulait que je lui il débranche
la machine et finalement j'ai attendu
toutes les familles partent pour pour
débrancher de faire ce geste débrancher
la machine comment il vous l'a dit qu'il
voulait me débrancher la machine
il l'a demandé on m'a toujours dit ma
gni s'il te plaît ne me laisse pas
mourir ne laisse pas sûr il avait
débranché la machine et je débrancher la
machine métier tout seul dans la maison
vous avez décidé avec la casi seul on
était de 3 personnes et c'est vous qui
allez s'est remis à respirer
miraculeusement puisque le moment il
veut il veut partir il est encore
espérer 3 4 heures et puis il va et la
fin d'année souffler j'étais parti c'est
incroyable jean-michel the way ce que je
voulais dire c'est que les méthodes
qu'on utilise de penser à un geste
extrêmement dur pour un médecin parce
que nature été éduqués pour soigner
guérir vivent donc il est le médecin
c'est très dur de procéder à ce genre de
choses la méthode douce et qu'on injecte
en général un anesthésique pour endormir
les gens et on rajoute de la morphine
pendant longtemps longtemps longtemps
jusqu'à temps que ça s'accumule de telle
façon à être certains qu'ils souffrent
pas et au bout d'un moment il ya
tellement morphine que ça finit par un
arrêt respiratoire
donc voila mais en arrêtant la machine
vous avez provoqué vous n'avez pas
provoquer mais vous lui avait permis de
faire cet arrêt respiratoire qui là
qu'il a délivré parce qu'un problème de
dignité là dedans le perchiste la
dignité
ça veut dire vous êtes bien vous êtes
sur vos deux jambes et où vous rigolez
d'un pinceau pour votre fils pour vos
enfants pour votre entourage vous
devenez ce que vous n'avez pas envie
d'être donc à la dignité à protéger des
gens mario ensuite quand vous êtes
retrouvés dans la maison avec vos de
deux proches
la machine c'est difficile on appelle sa
maman on appelle son frère puis on
explique on avec le recul j'aurais dû le
faire avant parce que l'important c'est
la volonté de la personne qui s'ouvre et
c'est ça qu'on doit comprendre c'est que
effectivement on a envie de vivre le
plus longtemps possible avec les gens et
qu'on n'a pas envie de faire bouger les
gens comme ça gratuitement
on le fait dans des cas bien
récit il faut le faire au luxembourg en
belgique aux pays-bas en suisse ils le
font dans des cas où il n'y a pas de
possibilité de guérir voilà où les
médecins vous disent de toute façon il
va partir c'est une histoire de quelques
semaines effectivement quand il y a une
possibilité guérison faut même pas y
penser mais dans son cas lui
mais voilà la maladie de charcot il ya
rien il ya un médicament qui soi-disant
retarde dans quelques mois la maladie
mais voilà il n'y a rien du tout donc
oui il faut laisser la liberté aux
personnes qui souffrent moralement
psychologiquement et qui voit aussi les
siens souffrir de partir librement alors
mario vous étiez un candidat cud de la
star academy 1 ça nous fait très plaisir
de vos de vous revoir
alors vous vous en êtes où maintenant là
bas a coûté j'ai dit au magazine qui
s'appelle mais le magazine depuis dix
ans qui est en kiosque maintenant plus
loin de janvier et puis voilà je prépare
d'ailleurs un nouvel album qui sortira à
la fin de l'année et je tiens à le
préciser parce que je fais un album
aussi en pensant à mon papa qui a
toujours voulu que tout s'est toujours
battu pour moi il était fier de monde
ben oui c'est grâce à lui que j'ai pu
chanter que j'ai pu faire la star ac et
finalement il part trop tôt parce qu'il
part quand vous commencez finalement
avoir un lien d'amis avec votre papa
maintien voyez et donc dix ans de break
et puis c'est le moment de de revenir
pour me faire plaisir déjà en hommage à
100 notamment à mon papa et puis je
reverserai les droits en tout cas une
association qui lutte contre la maladie
de charcot parce que ça me tient à coeur
c'était ça faisait longtemps je lui
parler de ça mais c'était pas facile
voilà là on vous sont encore très ému
lui merci en tout cas mario d'abord il
est avec nous mario très beau témoignage
de mario